Cô của Li Điều và phòng chống thiên tay đến tấm dơ ngày mi trinh bày.
Thiên tay đã làm bốn người thêm mặt bốn người mất tích và chính người bị thương.
Điều tại tình hai châu, một lũ cũng làm hai mốt cân nhà bị sập, một chăm bốn mới tức cân nhà bị hương hàng.
Hai chăm bẩy mấy mâm hộ phải dây dời khẩn cấp và sống mít tương hôi nhà nghỉnh ngộng gió nập lột sắp lời.
Tiên tay còn kết thái hơi xấu trong chiming só hát tà lũa hoàn mầu.
Lâm chết hai mi tấm có ra sốc và sống mẹ con ra tầm.
Như tuyến cuốn lột tình lộ tại Lai châu, sân là bởi vì miên sản ra sắp lời.
Trong đó, một số vị trí trên cuốn lộ bà mì hai và đường tình một lệ chính,
vẫn chưa được thông tuyến.
Tổng thế thải về tài sản ứng tính và khoảng 2,5 năm tìm đồng.
Ngay sâu ký tìm tài sản ra, các địa phương đá hôi đặc lực lượng phương tiện
hỗ trợ người dân khắp phục hộ quả ổn định đưa sống.